your new scp foundation researcher on
tour of site 17 familiarizing yourself
with the location and its many anomalous
inhabitants it's the second largest
foundation containment site out there
and it's also the kind of job that most
junior researchers dream of low-risk
humanoid containment baby most of the
inhabitants in your sector are cordial
willing to comply with orders from staff
and seeing for all intents and purposes
pretty much human you pass from door to
door looking through the viewing hatch
of each one you can't believe what
you're seeing it's a wonderful who's who
of anomalous humanoids you see the wise
bearded face of scp-343
known to some as god you see the blue
eyes and shining blonde hair of iris
scp-105 looking wistfully into a
polaroid picture you see the tanned
melancholic face of kane
scp-073 as he stares off into the middle
distance face after face after face
passes you can see yourself getting more
familiar with each one yes your time
here will be wait was that hitler you
stop and walk back to the door you just
passed where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him it's got
to be him you recognize the unpleasant
sneer the hideous comb over the silly
little toothbrush mustache the scp
foundation seems to have adolf hitler
the former leader of the third reich in
world war ii in active containment and
his designation is scp-2430
you've seen killer toasters and masks
that can take over people's minds but
you've never seen anything as surreal as
this you immediately run to your
superior and ask how and why hitler is
in one of the site-17 humanoid
containment cells buckle in because we
can guarantee it's one of the most
insane stories you've ever heard it's
late april 1945 and the soviets are
rampaging through nazi germany
destroying everything in their path the
german forces have been nearly
obliterated and hitler and the rest of
his reich chancellery have retreated to
a secure bunker beneath berlin there on
april 30th 10 days after his 56th
birthday hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the soviets as they
wished to have had the chance to kill
him themselves two days later soviet
forces stormed the furore bunker it was
little more than a formality at that
point as the news of hitler's death had
already gone public by the time they
arrived all that was left of hitler was
a pile of mostly burned remains a
fitting end for someone who had caused
the same cruel fate for so many others
they collected what was left of hitler's
body and brought it back to the
fatherland a kind of trophy for their
nation but hitler dying before joseph
stalin could get his hands on him was
not what stalin wanted hitler had not
only caused the deaths of millions of
russians he had personally betrayed
stalin's trust and when you betray
stalin
bad things happen to you
very
very bad things two years earlier in
1943
soviet forces had raided a camp in
jenowska belonging to the obscura corpse
think of them as the nazi's own version
of the scp foundation who were hell-bent
on gathering anomalous people and
artifacts to increase the power of the
third reich they were a far more
militant offshoot of the tule society a
group that described itself as a study
group for germanic antiquity while this
may seem innocent the teo society was
actually a racist cult closely aligned
with the goals and ideas of the german
nazi party many have also speculated
that they were heavily involved in the
occult and it's this mysticism obsessed
offshoot that went on to form the
obscura corpse and in their janusca base
they'd obtained a hundred pieces of
enchanted occult flesh with human
skeletons embedded in each of them this
flesh was believed to originate from the
mythological cerimnir the beasts hunted
and eaten again and again by the
pantheon of norse gods having the
qualities of both a wild boar and a goat
the flesh can bond to skeletons and give
them a quality somewhat like immortality
any flesh cut from them will regrow time
and time again if given a rest period
now that he had both the flesh of
surimneer and hitler's burnt remains
stalin had an idea a perfect way to not
only bring satisfaction to the russian
people and the world but to finally
exact the true revenge that hitler had
denied to him he called it project
judica namely after the very bottom
level of hell reserved for betrayers
like judas a perfect tribute for an old
ally turned enemy he couldn't kill
hitler before but if stalin was going to
get the chance hitler needed to live
again for years stalin's top scientists
tried to use arcane methods to resurrect
hitler by combining his remains with the
flesh of suramir at times they even came
close to creating a new hitler but there
was one huge issue the creature they
created could not feel pain and for
stalin's plans of violent and painful
retribution the lack of suffering simply
would not do they destroyed what they
had created and went back to the drawing
board stalin would stop at nothing to
get what he wanted even if it meant
breaking every law of nature in the
process in order to make his twisted
dream a reality stalin formed an unholy
alliance with a group known as the
uralic flesh crafters a neo-circuit cult
that was a branch of the nightmarish
religion of sarkicism this group
essentially worships avatars of flesh
corruption and disease and are behind
some of the most terrifying and
disgusting anomalies out there including
the flesh that hates and the bone
orchard true sarcasts who show the
proper devotion to their vile deities
and know the right rituals to contact
them are often granted anomalous powers
that spread the sarkic influence further
across the known dimensions these powers
will usually involve having a
supernatural ability to manipulate the
flesh of themselves and others allowing
them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies beyond repair
they can sometimes even create life if
they're a powerful enough acolyte of
sarkicism and it was because of these
powers that stalin wanted the uralic
flesh crafters under his command in
exchange for their participation he
would give them a vast quantity of the
flesh of suramir which they could use
for their own sinister sarkic purposes a
deal was struck and the true work of
resurrecting hitler began stalin was
very specific in his requirements he
gave the uralic flesh crafters extra
bones to compensate for what had gone
missing from hitler's burnt remains he
also gave them samples of the flesh of
ceramir to achieve the desired effects
of a near immortal tolerance for damage
however stalin demanded that he
heightened this new hitler's capacity to
experience pain so that every suffering
inflicted on him would be three times
worse than anyone else and true to their
word the flesh crafters got to work and
began creating just such a creature by
now it was the early 1950s and stalin
was putting the pieces in place for his
grand revenge once the new hitler was
finished he would hold a new trial for
him in the russian courts where he would
preside over the sentencing personally
once the new hitler was done the uralic
flesh crafters were rewarded for their
participation in project utica with 4
000 kilograms of the flesh of ceramir
stalin now had his very own personal
hitler chew toy that he could maim and
torture as much as he pleased knowing
that he would always heal and soon be
ready for more in their infinite
generosity the fleshcrafters even taught
stalin a new method of torment for his
old enemy a process known as the right
of nyas it's a torture that's been
described by many as being like the
chinese lingqi also known as the
lingering death or slow slicing but it
is probably best known as the death by a
thousand cuts the soviets and the
sarkics parted ways for the next few
years stalin took a great deal of
pleasure in visiting hitler's cage now
and then to torture him until stalin
himself eventually passed away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the soviet answer to the
scp foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal hitler
clone after stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never escape until of course he
was dug up and rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
corpse like many high-profile nazis
who'd escaped the war the new hitler was
spirited away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in argentina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondence from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
hitler back up they have managed to
rescue sephirah and bring him to safety
but he is effectively dead on the inside
i blame the reds for their inhumane
treatment of zifura who may have been
bewitched by the reds van der waals i
wish we could mercy kill him but we've
tried everything he just won't perish
don't abandon him he's too distinct in
plain sight they didn't have the new
hitler for long though in 1960 efforts
to hunt down the remaining nazi
fugitives increased in intensity the new
hitler was soon captured by mossad
agents searching for nazis in buenos
aires and then remanded to the
containment of the scp foundation when
they realized that he had a number of
anomalous properties such as his
incredible regenerative abilities as
well as the fact that his dna seems to
be based on that of a wild boar and a
goat rather than a human however x-rays
conducted by the foundation have
discovered traces of cyanide still in
his system as well as traces of lead in
his skull where the bone has regrown
over the bullet in other words it was
unquestionably the real hitler and he
was now in foundation custody
forevermore it's such a wild story even
by foundation standards that you can
barely summon the words to respond once
your supervisor is finished he just
stands there with a slight smile basking
in your amazement before you can even
ask again he confirms the facts one more
time yes it is the real hitler the only
functional difference is that he can't
die and he has a heightened sense of
pain compared to most people you think
on what you've been told for just a
moment and then you have only one
question are we allowed to punch him
your supervisor smiles and says of
course we all do now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms
wintershimer and
scp-3999 i'm at the center of everything
that happens to me for more nightmarish
scps